I thought a lot about public education
in science because it's important to me
the kids get get exposure to some of the
greatest ideas that humans have ever
developed and and just to enjoy them I
don't think there's one magic bullet to
solving our problems of Education but
there are a number of issues that I
think are useful to consider one is we
rely too much on teaching answers on
facts what's interesting are the
questions the questions are under
natural every kid grows up asking where
did I come from where am I going you
know am I alone in the universe these
fascinating questions but they don't
realize that they are the questions that
scientists ask and so I would like to
base a curriculum more on questions and
answers because the process of asking
the questions and figuring out how to
address them is what science is all
about the answers are not important
because most kids won't necessarily
become scientists but the tools of
science of trying to explore the
universe and distinguish sense from
nonsense and take a complicated
situation and simplify it enough to
address it and the fact that science
addresses the most remarkable questions
that are in each of us are the things we
want to instill in children so it would
be great to develop a curriculum where
we base it on the very questions that
kids are interested in I often tell
teachers and it's true for car salesmen
or or or web producers or interview
everything else that the biggest mistake
any teacher makes is to assume their
students are interested in what they're
saying because if you are a teacher or a
writer or anyone else what you have to
do is you have to go out to where they
are and convince them that what you're
talking about is relevant to what they
were interested in you have to seduce
them as I often say and seducing them
means recognizing that science is
actually relevant to the things that
they care about it's not things rolling
down on some inclined plane or boring
stuff it's are we alone in the universe
can we travel through time all of those
you know questions that people are
fascinated by now the problem with this
of course is that if teachers are going
to teach it they have to be comfortable
enough to with the material
to be able to go off in in different
directions and one of the big problems
is our teachers aren't trained in
science I like close to 90% of middle
school science teachers don't have a
training in science beyond the high
school level now if you're not
comfortable with the material what
you'll inevitably do is teach to the
curriculum you'll you'll you'll feel
comfortable with the answers that are in
the book and you'll teach to that so we
need to real problem of course is we
need to do a better job of training
teachers so they can feel comfortable to
go off in different directions if
they'll express a level of discomfort
that comes down to the students I
remember when my daughter was just in
grade 2 I went into her class and I saw
their teacher you know there they were
they were learning that it's like during
the day and dark at night trivial little
little bits of information about the
universe but the teacher was clearly
uncomfortable with it and I was sure
that level of discomfort was coming
through the students so we have to do a
much better job of training teachers
that means we have to build a better
curriculum which of course requires more
emphasis and at the university level and
the realization that when we're teaching
students were not trying to make clones
of ourselves when we teach physics we
tend to think that the students that the
results really matter that everyone
needs to know how to things will fall
down inclined planes I don't give a damn
about that I want students to realize
the process of how to do it because most
of them aren't going to become
physicists and it doesn't matter it's
that process that will be useful to them
later in life now if we are going to
spend more time and effort training
teachers then in some sense we have to
provide them a motivation to become
teachers and one of the things that that
I would argue which which I know is
controversial is that in some sense we
have to consider the competitive
environment that teachers find
themselves in I don't think that science
and math are more important than writing
I believe in communication it's
incredibly important I write but for
better or worse in the free market if
you have a training in science
in general you can go out and not become
a teacher and earn more money than you
would if you were a teacher so I think
we have to consider paying in order to
recruit better teachers who have a
training in science and mathematics the
possibility of differential pay scales
to accommodate the free market I know
many teachers unions would be vastly
opposed to that but I think we at least
have to consider that possibility if we
want to recruit the people with the
skills into the schools to be able to
connect with the students